mondiale vocal été unanimement salué par
la critique qui elle se produira le 19
janvier au prisme dans le cadre de ces
fameux jazz club
voici clotide rouleau dans le kiosque au
delà voilà elle les partis illuminé la
langue à piles pas pire imaginez
mouvement chaloupés mag à mark damon va
barder tiana et une partie roulante dans
son petit appelé m'a fallu neuf leurs
illusions des cadeaux mais joli vent de
l'art du trio et que les havaianas
c'est par la flûte traversière
effectivement quand j'étais petit
quand j'étais au cnr un saint germain en
laye la prof de solfège en fait a fait
venir une nana qui était chanteuse de
jazz pour justement un atelier alors là
j'ai vraiment j'ai adoré à
adversaire c'est quand même un
instrument qui est assez proche de la
voix dans l' approche technique dans la
colonne d'air dans la gestion du souffle
et c'est même en termes de thé stich
auxerre c'est assez proche se situe au
de mezzo donc
ap un logique du milieu des registres
des femmes effectivement très très
proche du registre de la flûte
traversière donc c'est drôle
effectivement il n'est pas que quand
j'ai voulu un petit peu travaillé plus
précisément l'art du scat avec sara
lazarus sarah m'a fait remarquer
effectivement que j'ai improvisé comme
une flûtiste
écoutez ma voix et toute ma prière de
mon coeur je préfère je tendrais le sa
page
je compte me revoilà
nous sommons
je ne
le
aho
à
oh
souvent je vois des couleurs je vois des
paysages voit des images en sept ans
j'ai improvisé et j'essaye de
retranscrire ce que je vois derrière mes
yeux avec la musique l'improvisation
dans le jazz on chante pour moi là
vraiment suivi toujours l'évolution des
musiciens peut-être quelque chose qui
revient aujourd'hui en tout cas j'ai le
sentiment qu'à plus en plus de
vocalistes qui a envie de retrouver
cette cette similitude
cette approche similaire entre la voix
et les instruments en revanche c'est
quelque chose qu'on a gardé dans la
tradition des chants du monde dans la
tradition indienne l'improvisation est
fondamental dans la tradition du chant
indien
oh
c'est vraiment dernier album in extremis
il est assez métissé on va dire il ya
pas mal d'influx en ski doo qui se
mélangent par rapport au premier qui
était la grosse tête les harkis qui
restait plus dans la tradition des
standards j'ai eu cette chance de
toujours être dans un brassage des
influences et pour moi la musique ne
doit pas de cloisonner et c'est
peut-être pour ça aussi que j'adore le
jazz votre finalement de similitudes
dans différentes musiques des parties du
monde c'est drôle on par exemple la
couleur bleue quand on dit dans le blues
en fait on a retrouvé aussi dans la
musique tzigane et
l'album in extrémiste il est sorti en
france en février 2011
et puis derrière on l'a sorti donc
royaume uni en allemagne benelux japon
il vient de sortir aux états unis il va
sortir en australie asie et canada
l'année prochaine c'est vrai qu'on a on
est ravi parce que c'est un album qui a
reçu un bel éclat mation de la critique
assez systématiquement donc
donc on a été dans les 10 meilleurs
albums de jazz 2011 par le sunday times
donc en royaume uni on a été sélection
fip sur radio france
on a fait aussi partie des sélections de
l'année 2011 donc
enfin jacques chesnais l'analyse de
citizen jazz par guy sitruk journaliste
de l'ats à paris
pour prisme donc le 19 janvier on a le
plaisir de venir qui on va donc
présenter l'album in extremis où ce sera
globalement les chansons de l'album
j'essaye en tout cas de de tenir compte
de l'atmosphère qui se dégage du lieu
des gens c'est ça qui est magnifique
avec le live c'est ce partage avec le
public perpétuelle mon idée c'est
vraiment de recevoir la musique qui est
là dans l'air et la laisser me traverser
et donc je serai entouré des musiciens
du disque je suis ravie en train de
pianoter à la batterie d'anheuser à la
guitare cette corde et olivier heckmann
au piano c'est trois grands humain
et maintenant un nouveau sujet de la
rédaction ces élèves de la classe
orchestre du collège des soldes
guyancourt viennent de recevoir leurs
instruments c'est leur tout premier
cours est pour l'instant ces apprentis
musicienne essaie de faire connaissance
avec leurs flûtes traversières site
placé le petit toit en fait ça fait très
cantous souffler dans la puce avait pas
forcément un bruit faut bien souffler
dans le trou la classe orchestre
s'effectue sur trois années scolaires
jusqu'en classe de 3e les élèves du
collège des saules suivent deux heures
de cours par semaine
la première en ateliers pratiques la
seconde en tutti le moment où toutes les
familles d'instruments violon guitare
basse percussions et flûte se
rassemblent pour former l'orchestré le
plaisir de jouer reste le maître mot car
les collégiens ne sont pas notés par
leurs professeurs nous un premier temps
avoir un joli son et puis maîtrisé donc
la pause et doigt sur chaque clé ce qui
va demander un petit certain temps
qu'ils savent jouer quelques notes
qu'ils sachent qui est un petit peu les
partitions quelques rythmes mais le but
est le nombre des gens semblent ses
vingt apprentis musiciens devront être
prêts pour leur première représentation
officielle à la fin de l'année scolaire
en attendant ils se sont déjà produits
sur scène en chansons lors de la
cérémonie de remise des instruments
et encore quelques dates à retenir avant
de débuter le régime post fait le 19
janvier le circassien pascal rousseau
présentera le mur de l' équilibre à la
merise attrape le 19 janvier toujours
pierre cassignard thierry frémont et
samuel le bihan s'illustreront dans la
pièce hollywood à la ferme du manet à
montigny le 22 janvier antoine hervé
proposera ses leçons de jazz consacré
cette fois à dave brubeck au prisme à
elancourt et du 24 au 26 janvier
godefroy ségal présentera plus que le
tumulte des eaux profondes à la ferme de
bel ébat à guyancourt des dates que vous
pouvez retrouver ainsi que l'ensemble de
la programmation culturelle des salles
saint-quentinoise dans le kiosque sur
internet aux adresses qui s'affiché
cette semaine sur le www.cascades.com
qui point fr vous pouvez gagner des
places de spectacle du 8 au 14 janvier
pour plus que le tumulte des eaux
profondes de godefroy ségal à la ferme
de bel ébat
le cachet de la balle